at the US Open last night Rafael Nadal
beat Matteo Bertini to advance to the
tournament final he'll face daniil
Medvedev in the men's Championship match
tomorrow afternoon between now and then
both players will get help preparing
their most important pieces of game gear
their rackets brook silva-braga has been
looking into just how elite players get
outfitted for the open and other major
tournaments all year long by the time
Roger Federer steps on to a tennis court
it's already been a long day for Ron you
the 4:30 wake up to started stringing
tennis racquets is not the most
pleasurable thing in the world for the
last 15 years in nondescript hotel rooms
around the world ron has personally
strung federer's racquets nine fresh
ones
each match this racquet will be used in
like six or seven hours yes and then
what happens to it it gets back to me
and I cut off the strings you kind of
know what's wrong with the strings they
lose tension quickly yeah the same swing
could correlate to a few inches that's
in an alcohol right there most pros just
use local stringers provided by the
tournament and that was good enough for
the players who made this year's US Open
finals but for a hefty fee some elite
players hire one stringer to follow them
around the world
while Ron paints the wilts and logo on
federer's rackets just over there on the
left is Glen Roberts stringing for Novak
Djokovic another tennis great what's the
pitch to these guys that your service is
worth it consistency I mean they're very
good stringers out there who are on-site
stringers but everyone might swing
slightly different that fixation on
consistency is what created the personal
stringing business a von Lendl a star of
the 1980s obsessed over perfectly strong
racquets and other top players soon
noticed Mats Wilander was ranked number
one in the world in the late 80s it's
comfort we want to be a hundred percent
sure that your rackets are exactly the
same exactly how you want them
normal player I'm telling you that
you're not going to feel that difference
but for these guys yes of course they
feel it's gonna affect the balance and
the swing weight but before strings even
go on a frame someone like Roman proulx
has studied the player's swing to decide
exactly how to build their racket in
2017 he suggested changes for Djokovic
it became somewhat predictable on the
court where he can go with certain shots
because the racket wouldn't allow him to
use the whole court that's you know from
certain shots you took away some of the
strengths we actually took away a little
bit of strings so he can generate more
spin you know we made a racket lighter
we made the way distribution on the rack
and different after two minutes of
hitting Novak basically said throw all
my rackets away this is my new rocket
[Applause]
but this level of customization presents
another challenge each one has to be
handmade all tennis racquets come out
from the most looking like this out of
the factory as this machine reveals no
two are exactly the same so it's telling
me to add you know 9.1 gram at this part
of the handle because if I put a little
bit of weight this is actually a lot of
weight 9 grams on a tennis racket is a
lot of weight it feels like nothing no
no that's a lot of weight after the
weighted tape comes the handle mix it up
Custom Fit in hand port close the mold
after 45 minutes it's gonna look just
like this shave off a couple thousandths
of an inch and it's ready for play it
takes about three hours three hour
rocket and when you watch a guy smash it
on the court what do you feel pitching
[Laughter]
they have a plenty more rockets in the
back and I can always make more roaming
charges about $500 per racket he has a
shop here in New York he'll make them
for anyone but the guys who do federer's
rackets said they will not they get lots
of requests they will not make the
identical racket because they're afraid
people go on eBay and sell them oh yeah
make sense is it a record standard they
have a lot of leeway and it's been
interesting how it evolves they now use
different strings they then they did
years ago the shape and size of the
racket has changed as well I tell you
what what do you think when they swear
they smash your record thank you so much